こんにちははじめしゃちょーですえー
珍しく珍しくちょっと緊急で動画を撮って
おりますこんにちははじめしゃちょーです
今日のコメントを読んでいきますはい今日
のコメント読んでおいていこうと思った
けど見てください読み込みエラー再試行
するにはタップしてください
wi-fiバリさんはい
誰だ誰
幽霊かじゃあ見てもらったら分かると思う
んですけどもwi-fiがバリさん
ちゃんとMAXで飛んでるのに
ネットが繋がらないんですよ
すいませんというわけで今日はコメント
読めません本日はじめしゃちょーですはい
というわけであの動画のタイトルにもある
んですけどもあの
釣りではなく結構ガチな方です端的に話さ
せていただくとえーこの3億円のお家に
進めなくなりました住めなくというより
仕事ができなくなったまあ正直仕事がこの
家でできなかったらもう僕ここいる意味
ないなと思ってるんで
正直言います多分ここにしばらく攻めない
と思いますで具体的に何が起きたかと言い
ますと今スマホ見てもらっても分かったと
思うんですけど
wi-fiがMAXで飛んでるのにネット
が繋がらないんですよこれ何が起きている
かというとネットがつながってないんです
ね今この家wi-fiが飛んでるけど
はい
ネットが遮断されました
もう
終わりだよねとかなくなったらいやいや
そんなネットなくなったぐらいで何を
投げとるお前って言うじゃないですかこの
家で結構丈夫であの全面コンクリートで
作られててその次この辺を見てもらったら
分かると思うんですけど電波がないんすよ
想像電波数字にくい家なんでwi-fiが
ないとマジで正直何もか活動できない
ネット活動できない
ネット活動車からネットを取り上げられた
状態それすなわち死ですなんかポケット
wi-fiとかでなんとか繋がったりする
んですよ上とかに行けばけども本当に遅く
て1時間とかかかるんですよ動画上げるの
にで編集データのやり取りとかもできない
動画のアップロードもできないオンライン
ミーティングに妹会議もできない
エロサイトも見れない実質
YouTuberにとってはライフライン
が立たれたような状態でございますこの家
でそこそこ何でこんなことが起きたかと
いうとしっかりと謝罪文を頂いております
3億円のうちずっと今工事とかも続いてる
んですよセキュリティー面の強化だったり
エレベーターもついてるんですけどまだ
壊れてて動いてないそこも今直してもらっ
てたりあと照明が全体的に暗いから照明も
つけてもらっているガスト電気とかも
すごい高かったから構造変えようと思って
色とかやってもらってたりいろんなコース
をこの家で日々やっていただいてる中と
ある工事が行われていた後にネットが全く
繋がらなくなったっていうことが起きて
しまいました見てください
本家の概要インターネットにつながらない
ま別にこの会社を攻めたいわけではないの
で色々不正させていただくんですけれども
関係者様に多大なるご迷惑をおかけして
申し訳ございませんというちょ謝罪文も
いただいている状態でございます
俺悪くないからね俺何も悪くないから俺
本当にあのなんかそういうやらせとかじゃ
なくて俺俺もう外的要因になるんで私あの
悪くありませんまああの知りませんといっ
たものの正直ネットが繋がらないと本当に
あの何もできなくてですねまあちょっと
だいぶ整ってきてはいたんですけども
しばらく
この家を
離れます
どこへそうですよねどこへって思うじゃ
ないですか皆さんこんな時もあろうかと
ちゃんと前進でたお家まだ解約せずとって
おいてあります
本当に良かった
本当に解約しなくてよかったもう何かあっ
た時のために一応前のうち借りてたんです
よずっとでネットもまだ繋がってるんで
一応編集とかもできるんですけどなんせね
ちょっともう生活ができないともうベッド
とかも全部こっち映したし服とかタオルと
かもありとあらゆる生活用品がこっちに
持ってきちゃってるんでまず何すればいい
んだろうなっていうとりあえずパソコンと
か全部移動させなきゃね
だるいでは別にあの怒ってるわけないん
ですけどなんか別にこんな悲しいことが
あったら怒ってるんだあっていう動画を
撮りたいわけじゃなくて
突然3億円の家から前のうちに戻ったら
びっくりするのかなと思いましてなんか
過去動画だと思われても言わなくて
ちょっとご報告したいなと思って一応動画
にさせていただいております基本的に動画
撮る時はこの家に戻ってくるけど多分生活
したりとか編集とか
活動の拠点になるのは前のお家になると
思いますちょっとごめんネット繋がらない
と本当に何もできない
住めないマジでというちょっとごめん
なさい緊急で撮ってるんですけどご報告の
動画になりますそんなことあるんだね
調査してもらったんですよなんでこんな
ことが起きたのって地上ですね
光回線を損傷させたのではないかという
ことにはなっておりますただほんとそれ
までバチバチネット繋がってたのに急に
繋がんなくなってで今やっぱ新生活が
始まってる時期だからなんかそう
混んでるんですよねネットを引くその業者
さんがすごい忙しくてなかなかすぐに工事
をしてもらえずしばらくは多分この家に
ネットが通ることはないとでコンクリート
だらけでスマホの電波もまともに通らない
私はこの家での活動生活断念して
前のお家に一時的に戻らせていただきます
でも別に工事の人もさ悪気があってそんな
ネットの回線遮断するわけないじゃない
ですか普通に考えだから本当にミスだった
んだろうなと思ってはいるんですけども
それでもやっぱり何でしょうこれ俺がもし
ゲーム実況者さんだったらもう
終わってましたよ本当にゲーム実況とか生
配信されてる方だと思う
ネットがなくなったらどうしちゃったん
だろうとか思ってじゃあこういうことも
あるためになんかサブネット回線とかも
引いといた方がいいのかなと思いました
これマジで結構やばいっすよデスクトップ
のパソコンでかいの170万の2個また
運ばなきゃいけないし
生活どうするんだろうね服とか
色々困ってるんですけども早速明日から
またプチ引っ越しですねちょっとだけ移動
させて前のお家で生活することにします
怒ってるわけじゃなくて純粋に
ショップというか
[音楽]
うわーそうですかっていう
感じですねまあおかげで動画1本撮れてる
んでああ出すではないですけど普通にやや
ダメでしょってなりますけど起きたものは
しょうがないということで明日から
向こうでまた新生活が始まります
じゃあまた明日
向こう行ってくるね
久しぶりそういうわけで帰ってきました
久々の
元
初めてのお口です
取っといてよかったーこっち解約してたら
もう帰れる場所なかったんで本当に仕事が
できなかったっていう状態でまだ
wi-fiを繋いでるし賃貸としてまだ
変えてるんで帰ってくることができました
マジ良かった本当に
逆に910の方はもう終わりでしたからね
本当にそういうわけで
パソコンだけあればとりあえずデータの
やりたいとかアップロードとかできるので
作業しております
俺とスタックで編集するんで一応2台置か
せてもらって
撮影はもうここですることは基本的にない
と思ってるんであと物持ってきたよねする
のが誰じゃん普通とかベッドとかなので
もう最低限の編集するものだけ持ってきて
ここで動画編集作業をしばらくすることに
なると思います
懐かしい気持ちがあるからいいんですけど
普通にもうこれの運び込みが超大変でした
私120万ぐらいするんでここでもう
250万ぐらいそれを
持って
壊さないようにディスプレイとか持って
くるのもまた一袋だったと言いますか
YouTuberにとって
ネットが繋がらないっていうのは自殺問題
もう正直ね
綺麗な時点でYouTuberにある私は
あそこには進めないと
仕事にならないと
判断して
奇跡的に解約していなかった前の家に戻っ
てくることができましたはいというわけで
ちょっとあの緊急事態になってしまって
いるんですけどもいち早く3億円のゲーム
を戻ることを祈っておりますというか
YouTuber
ネットナイターちょっと苦しいなというか
あの死活問題
誰か悪いとかそういうわけではないです
けど
マジかっていう感じ
結構今動画編集するもの溜まってるんで
撮影する時は3億円の落ち着いて平日の時
はちょっと
離れてるんですけどこの家に来てそして
仕事の時は東京3億円この家東京です
[音楽]